[Music]
UK prime minister Rishi sunak says he's
cancelling phase two of what was once
touted as the UK's biggest
infrastructure project he announced the
decision in his keynote speech rounding
off the conservative party's annual
conference well sunak blames doubling
costs for why he's canceling a
high-speed Railway meant to connect
London to Birmingham in his speech sunak
tried to betray himself as the best
choice to lead the UK ahead of expected
elections next year
hs2 is the ultimate example of the old
consensus the result is a project whose
costs have more than doubled which has
been repeatedly delayed and it is not
scheduled to reach here in Manchester
for almost two decades and for which the
economic case has massively been
weakened with the changes to business
travel
postco I say to those who back the
project in the first place the facts
have changed and the right thing to do
when the facts change is to have the
courage to change
direction the hs2 was estimated to cost
about $38 billion when it was green lit
10 years ago but in 2020 that estimate
increased threefold the high-speed rail
line was meant to connect London to
Manchester the first phase from London
to Birmingham is already being built
however the second phase is set to be
scrapped that connects Birmingham to
Manchester $2.8 billion has already been
spent on this
phase for more on this we're going to uh
be joined Now by Chris Wilkins who is a
former director of strategy for prime
minister Teresa may he joins us from Sur
in the UK thank you very much for
joining us on El jaera uh Chris we'll
get to the hs2 in just a moment but as
any of what Rishi sunk had to say here
actually going to make a difference for
him personally as leader do you think
it's shifted momentum back towards
him I think it's uh a big gamble the
Prime Minister has taken today what he
was trying to do in his uh big
conference speech was set really the
question that he wants people to have in
their mind when they go to the polls in
the general election next year he wants
to make that question really a question
about him he wants people to ask
themselves they want him to be prime
minister or uh his opposite number the
labor leader and what he can't afford
for that question to be is do you want
another term of a conservative
government because the conservatives
have been in power for 13 years and he
knows if that is the question people
have in their minds and they'll answer
no so he's trying to say look I'm not a
typical conservative I'm Different uh
this is about me uh and choose me to be
your prime minister and that's what he
what he set out today I think the
challenge for that is that after 13
years of being in government it's very
very difficult to do it's very difficult
things to set yourselves up as as the
change candidates he's trying to do and
also in the speech itself the policies
he announced didn't really live up to
that billing they weren't that radical
they weren't particularly bold um and so
I'm not sure what he was trying to do
would actually have succeeded in the
speech he's given you're a former
director of strategy for uh for another
prime minister Teresa may I mean what
would your advice be for him over the
next 12 months or so uh leading up to
the
election well it's a strange choice he's
made you know elections basically you go
into and there are two ways of doing it
you either say look I am the change
candidate the country wants change
that's me that's the decision made the
alternative is to say actually um you
know things are going okay we're moving
in the right direction stick with me and
the likely context for the general
election next year is that we've had
very difficult economic circumstances in
the UK this year but next year it is
expected the economy will be improving
um and things will be starting to feel a
bit better so you would have thought the
logical thing strategically to do is to
take that approach and say look actually
I know it's been difficult but stick
with me we're moving in the right
direction don't throw everything out now
because you don't know what the other
people will will offer now that's not
the choice he's made he's chosen to be
the change candidate okay that's fine
but if you're going to do that you have
to have policies and proposals that live
up to that billing and I just don't
think they've been there to say they a
big challenges in the in the United
Kingdom um that the government faces um
but he's not actually addressing those
and the policies he's talked about today
are really quite small things um which
aren't really the things that are
people's concerns so choose a strategy
either be change or don't But whichever
you do you've got to have the policies
that live up to it and I think at the
moment he's probably falling between the
two right I mean on one of those
policies so much has been made about the
hs2 high-speed train line in your eyes
has he made the right decision
here well it's a very controversial
topic people have strong views on this
my own view uh is that uh hs2 is a good
big strategic initiative that um
government has been pursuing now for
over 10 years and we should see through
um so I think it's a shame that he's
made the decision he has to have
scrapped it um but it's not something
he's ever really believed in and he's
scrapping it and in putting the money
he's saving which is 36 billion pound
into more specific localized transport
schemes now I think that's a good
shortterm thing to do because it means
people might get a sense of money being
spent in their area ahead of the
election but hs2 was actually also about
encouraging investment into the United
Kingdom creating jobs um and uh
demonstrating that United Kingdom is a
sort of forward-looking country and I
think having now vote back on that um I
think the message it sends is a very bad
one okay thank thank you so much have to
leave it there that is Chris Wilkins
former director of strategy for prime
minister Teresa may thanks so
much